salut c'est Lucas BR nature ces chiens
avec leurs têtes aplaties beaucoup les
trouvent super mignons et j'ai découvert
que ces physiques pouvaient leur créer
de graves problèmes de santé et que
c'était en grande partie à cause de nous
de mettre complètement la santé de côté
des animaux à terme ça cré des individus
qui ne sont pas fait pour vivre ou qui
sont en grande souffrance tout au long
de leur vie des pays comme les Pays-Bas
ou la Norvège ont même voulu interdire
l'élevage de certaines de ses races
comme le bulldog anglais ou le cavalier
kingcha à côté de ça d'autres
scientifiques et des professionnels
tentent de trouver d'autres solutions
pour tenter de réduire ses souffrances
pour ce nouvel épisode de la grande
explication j'ai donc voulu comprendre
pourquoi ces chiens ont plus de chance
de souffrir quelles peuvent être les
solutions je vous
explique on peut commencer cette
histoire ici en Norvège dans un tribunal
d'Oslo début 2022 ce tribunal décide
d'interdire l'élevage de deux races de
chien lui le bulledog anglais et lui le
cavalier king charles les juges
considèrent alors que la reproduction de
ses races est contraire au bien-être
animal et c'est notamment à cause des
problèmes de santé qui les touchent ça
avait fait beaucoup de bruit à l'époque
en fait mais c'est factuellement assez
complexe d'interdire une race j'avoue
que j'ai été étonné par cette
interdiction alors j'ai interviewé deux
vétérinaires pour mieux comprendre les
problèmes de santé qui touchent sa race
alors même que certaines connaissent un
succès croissant le bouledog Fran frça
est dans le top 20 des races les plus
élevées en France un chien d'une race à
nez court qui respire pas normalement et
bien ce n'est pas normal pour commencer
voyons concrètement de quelle souffrance
on
[Applaudissements]
parle certains peuvent avoir tendance à
trouver ça mignons ces petits
ronflements mais en fait il faut avoir
conscience que un chien qui ronfle c'est
un chien qui a du mal à respirer on l'a
intégré dans quelque chose qui fait
partie de l'animal ça a pas l'air de
trop le déranger sauf qu'il est en
souffrance respiratoire toute sa vie
hein cet animal ces signes on a beaucoup
plus de chance de les retrouver chez les
bullledogs Anglais les bullldogs
Français et d'autres races qu'on appelle
les brachicéphales très simplement en
grec braaki ça veut dire court et
Céphale c'est la tête donc en gros on
les appelle comme ça parce que
contrairement à des races comme les
lévriers russes ou des races comme le
labrador par exemple les brachicéphales
ont des faces beaucoup plus courtes ou
entre guillemets aplatis mais alors quel
rapport avec la santé dans plusieurs
études le scientifique britannique dan
Onil a comparé des milliers de chiens
brachicéphales à des milliers de chiens
d'autres races d'abord il a constaté une
différence significative d'espérance de
vie d'un côté les labradors retriever ou
d'autres races vivaient autour de 12 ans
mais les bouledogs Français et les
carlins eux vivaient en moyenne 8 ans ça
fait un tiers de moins alors ça ça peut
s'expliquer par une multitude de
facteurs qui vont au-delà de la santé
mais voilà ce que danonil a montré
spécifiquement en terme de problèmes de
santé les ulcères de la cornée par
exemple donc des problèmes aux yeux ils
étaient 8,4 fois plus présents chez des
chiens anné courts que chez les autres
races les problèmes de souffle cardiaque
3,5 fois plus fréquents et pour les
problèmes respiratoires ou ce qu'on
appelle le sorb c'était plus de 30 fois
plus cette notion de Sorbe justement
elle revient tout le temps quand on
s'intéresse à ce sujet ces syndromees
obstructiv des voies respiratoire des
races
brachicéphales comme tout syndrome c'est
un ensemble de symptômes c'est c'est
tout un tas d'éléments qui concourent
dans le même sens et qui qui font que
c'est une infection une pathologie un
problème respiratoire le premier signe
qu'on peut remarquer à la maison c'est
une intolérance à l'effort ça va être
des chiens qui en balade vont vite se
fatiguer comme le passage de l'air est
obstrué ça fait que le allaitement de
ces chiens il est gêné et donc ils ont
beaucoup plus de mal à thermoréguler et
et donc quand il fait très chaud ils ont
du mal à rester à maintenir leur corps à
la bonne température en fait quand on
parle de la respiration qui est gênée
c'est pas uniquement un problème
respiratoire c'est un problème de santé
bien plus général alors avant de bien
comprendre ce qui cause ces problèmes et
les solutions possibles on va faire un
petit retour dans le temps on va voir
comment l'humain a créé ses races et les
a fait
évoluer ça c'est une image du début du
20e siècle et ça c'est la même race mais
sur une image beaucoup plus récente
cette différence c'est pas forcément une
exception nous sommes au 19e siècle au
Royaume-Uni les premiers clubs de race
sont créés par des passionnés de chiens
pour définir les standards du Bou g
anglais c'est-à-dire la taille qu'il
doit avoir la forme de sa tête ou de sa
queue et cetera avant ça les bullldog
ils avaient été sélectionnés surtout
pour participer à des combats de taureau
et oui Bou dans Bulldog ça veut dire
taureau en anglais il fallait donc un
chien qui soit très puissant très massif
avec une une mâchoire énorme des gros
mus masticateurs pour pouvoir attaquer
le taureau des chiens pas trop haut pour
pas se faire encorner par le taureau les
combats de taureau ont ét interdits on
les a réutilisé en autre chose et on en
a fait des chiens de compagnie ils sont
devenus des agneaux ils sont devenus un
bullledog anglais ou un bulledog
Français à l'heure actuelle c'est c'est
hyper calme en plus du comportement le
physique a aussi évoluer et pour
comprendre il faut d'abord préciser ce
qu'on appelle le ratio ou l'indice
craniofacial c'est quand on prend la
longueur F du nez ou de la face et qu'on
la compare à la longueur C du reste du
crâne là par exemple la face fait 0,20
fois la taille du reste de la tête en
fait on peut progressivement changer le
ratio d'une race à travers la sélection
et la reproduction des chiens et pour
plusieurs races brakicéphal c'est ce qui
s'est passé à partir d'anciennes photos
de chien primé lors de concours Claude
gintard a tenté de retracer l'évolution
sur plus de 120 ans et si on met ses
résultats sous forme de graphique on
peut voir les tendances pour le
buouledog anglais le bouledog français
le carlin ou encore le Terrier de Boston
dans tous les cas le ratio a diminué
donc en gros leur face S globalement
aplati en fait l'homme a sélectionner
les chiens de manière générale pour ses
besoins donc pendant très longtemps on a
sélectionné les chiens pour être des
bons chasseur pour des bons compagnons
de travail et cetera et là la tendance
ces dernières années mais ces dernières
dizaines d'années hein ça remonte pas
c'est pas récent et plutôt d'avoir des
chiens d'agrément et de compagnie parce
que les éleveurs vont le vendre plus
facilement parce que les juges vont
trouver ça joli et vont primer l'animal
et bien on va accentuer des traits du
physique de la morphologie de l'animal
et au bout d'un moment on va aller vers
des ce qu'on appelle des hypertypes bon
j'avoue que perso ce terme d'hypertype
je l'avais jamais entendu donc on va
encore prendre un graphique pour
comprendre on a au milieu le standard
qui représente à la base la majorité des
chiens d'une race ils ont ce qu'on
considère comme les traits
caractéristiques entre guillemets
normaux pour cette race là dans
l'exemple du Carlin notamment quelques
plis et une face assez
courte mais parfois ces caractéristiques
sont moins marquées c'est l'hpotype dans
ce cas particulier il a moins de plis ou
un museau un peu plus long à l'inverse
on peut pousser tous ces critères
beaucoup plus loin donc avoir plus de
plis et des nez beaucoup plus courts et
c'est ça qu'on appelle l'hyperty le
standard c'est la majorité des animaux
c'est ce qui est défini et le problème
c'est que si tout le monde veut aller
vers un hypertype veut aller vers une
exagération du trait de caractère à la
fin l'exagération elle semble être la
norme et donc en fait c'est comme ça que
bah progressivement petit à petit on
décale le standard vers quelque chose de
plus hypertypé après cette petite
parenthèse historique revenons aux
souffrances associées à ces chiens parce
que j'ai découvert qu'il y avait un
lien on l'a dit par rapport à d'autres
races la plupart des races années cours
ont plus de chance de développer
certains problèmes de santé notamment
respiratoire et plusieurs de ces
problèmes sont regroupés dans ce qu'on
appelle le Sorbe mais je me suis demandé
qu'est-ce qui causait concrètement ces
problèmes en 2015 la scientifique Rowena
Parker a cherché à avir la probabilité
d'avoir le Sorbe en fonction du ratio
cranio facial donc grosso modo de cette
taille de la face dans son étude on
retrouve notamment des boules de
ganglais des bullledogs Français et des
carlins ce graphique montre que dans
chacune des espèces plus le chien a une
face courte plus il a de chance d'être
aussi touché par le SOR on voit donc une
corrélation entre les deux à partir de
02 c'est-à-dire 1/5e c'està dire quand
la quand la face ne représente qu'un/5e
de la longueur globale de la tête on
commence à avoir des problèmes mais on
on voit très bien que en dessous de 01
c'estàd quand la face ne représente que
pratiquement qu'un diè c'est il y a
pratiquement plus de nez il y a
pratiquement plus rien là les problèmes
montent en flèche et la probabilité
d'avoir un
Sorbe est très très forte du coup quand
j'ai vu ça je me suis dit bon ok c'est
simple quand on réduit la taille du
museau d'un chien et ben il va avoir le
Sorbe fin de l'histoire mais en fait il
y a pas que ça Claude gintard écrit dans
cet article que le Sorbe est une
affection plurifactorielle qu'il est
très réducteur de ne ramener qu'à un
seul paramètre en gros il y a d'autres
traits physiques qui sont pointus du
doigt comme pouvant entraîner le Sorbe
si on regarde de plus près par rapport à
un chien sain ça peut être d'abord des
narines plus étroite ce qu'on appelle
dans le jargon la sténose des narines ça
peut être aussi le nez ou la gorge plus
étroit ou t tueux ou encore le palais
mou trop long tout ça complique le
déplacement de l'air et donc la
respiration du chien d'où le ronflement
dont on a parlé au début de cette
vidéo et on peut ajouter que le sort
peut aussi être associé à d'autres
paramètres en dehors de la tête comme
l'obésité pour ces deux vétérinaires le
problème reste très lié à la sélection
des chiens hypertypes dont on a parlé en
fait ces hypertypes ils ont plus de
chance d'avoir un ou plusieurs
paramètres physiques propices au sord le
problème c'est que ce sont des animaux
hypertyp qui sont primés en concours et
ces individus là ils vont reproduire
énormément si on laisse filer comme ça
pendant 10 ou 20 ans c'est c'est la
moitié de la race qui va être atteintre
dans 20 ans quoi ok du coup est-ce qu'on
peut vraiment réduire ses souffrances et
comment nous sommes en 2019 au Pays-Bas
face à ces questions de bien-être animal
le pays est le premier à interdire la
reproduction de plusieurs races
ancho 3 ans plus tard on l'a dit c'est
un tribunal norvégien qui fait la même
chose pour deux de ses races du coup du
coup j'ai demandé à ces deux
vétérinaires s'il pensaient que ces
interdictions étaient des bons leviers
pour tenter de limiter ses problèmes de
santé ça aurait un sens ce qu'il propose
si l'intégralité des individus d'une
race était atteint par le SOR parce que
là on pourrait dire on sait plus comment
s'en sortir
et le seul moyen qu'on a c'est
d'éliminer cette race et on en parlera
plus euh c'est pas du tout le cas depuis
en Norvège un tribunal a d'ailleurs
réautorisé la reproduction des bullldog
Anglais à condition que les éleveurs
respectent plusieurs règles alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire un bouldog
anglais qui court et qui respire ça
existe un bouldog français qui court et
qui respire ça existe donc c'est ceux-là
qu'il faut encourager c'est ceux-là
qu'il faut sélectionner c'est ceux-là
qui doivent être les les futurs
géniteurs de la race donc il faut
trouver un moyen pour séparer le bon
grain de livret on va dire c'estàdire
les les animaux qui n'ont pas de sort
mais les animaux qui qui qui ont la
pathologie il y a bien sûr l'éleveur qui
avec le test breess qui est donc un test
d'aptitude qui permet de savoir si
l'animal respire normalement et à partir
de là ne ne reproduiront que ces
animauxl qui ont satisfait au test
d'aptitude la formation des juges canin
ça c'est fondamental parce que c'est eux
qui sélectionnent les futurs champions
et donc ceux qui vont reproduire les
vétérinaires qui doivent jouer le jeu
puisque chaque fois qu'ils opèent un
chien qui a du Sorbe il faut bien sûr
dire au propriétaire que cet animal là
ne devra pas reproduire ou en tous les
cas un minimum les éleveurs sont aussi
influencés par les standards des races
écrites par les autorités canines par
exemple la Fédération sinologique
internationale a récemment revu le
standard du bulldog français et a
supprimé l'obligation pour la facee de
faire un/ 6e de la tête le but c'est de
permettre d'aller vers des bouledogs
Français avec un nez un peu plus long
les Propriétaire ou futur propriétaire
ont aussi un rôle à jouer quand on veut
avoir un chien adopter un chien
l'acheter c'est se renseigner sur la
race sur les différents problèmes de
santé qui peut y avoir s'interroger sur
est-ce qu'on va être capable
financièrement d'en assumer les frais si
jamais il y a un souci aujourd'hui il y
a une opération donc qui consiste à
couper le nez à couper le fond du palais
il y a des chirurgies qui existent et
puis aussi tout simplement essayer de ne
pas aller forcément vers les fcièes les
plus hypertypé je tiens à préciser que
dans cette vidéo le but c'est pas du
tout de juger les propriétaires je suis
sûr que la très grande majorité adore
leurs animaux mais je trouva intéressant
de vous partager ce que j'ai découvert
de ces problèmes respiratoires et aussi
les potentielles
[Musique]
solutions
si cette vidéo vous a intéresser vous
pouvez la liker pour qu'elle touche un
public plus large vous pouvez aussi bien
sûr poser vos questions en commentaire
comme souvent voici un petit extrait
supplémentaire d'interview je me suis
demandé si à côté de ces problèmes de
santé ces races là dont on parle
pouvaent aussi avoir des plus par
rapport à d'autres races il y a une
étude anglaise qui a prouvé que elles
ont beaucoup moins de problèmes de
griffe beaucoup moins de problèmes
comportementaux et cetera que tout un
tas d' race euh mais parce qu'elles sont
protégées parce qu'elles sont élevées au
quotidien auprès de l'homme dans les
études qui ressort c'est que c'est des
chiens qui sont très gentils très
sociable avec l'humain et c'est aussi
pour ça que ils sont autant appréciés et
que autant de gens les aiment nous on se
retrouve dimanche prochain pour un
nouvel épisode de la grande explication
et je vous dis à bientôt